uh joining us now labour's shadow
international trade secretary nick
thomas simmons good to see you this
morning and as we were just discussing
before probably the first time i think
actually we've been in the studio
together so very nice to have you lovely
to see you um your thoughts on the
resignation of lord guy um dominic rabb
doesn't know why he's done it i suspect
you might have an idea
well i don't think it is surprising
given the conduct the appalling conduct
of this prime minister over a sustained
period of time that we see again an
independent ethics advisor leaving this
isn't the first time sir alex allen very
respected civil servant left his post
back in 2020 on that occasion it was the
home secretary who'd broken the
ministerial code by bullying and yet it
was the independent advisor who was the
one offering resignation not the home
secretary on this occasion we again
after the serial rule breaking the
absolute contempt for the british public
following the rules the prime minister
has shown we now see another independent
ethics advisor leaving it's the prime
minister who should be offering his
resignation frankly sure what we have i
mean it is a brief statement but as a
statement nonetheless in which uh lord
goes so far as to say well you know i
regret having to do this but this feels
like the right time to to to go i mean
i've lost kind of the number of times
that people have told me that lord gaia
is a man of deep integrity and deep
honor if that is the case if there is
some reason behind his resignation then
surely he would just come out and say so
publicly we do need to see it uh
publicly we absolutely do now lord kite
has previously commented in public that
it's a legitimate question as to whether
the prime minister broke the ministerial
code what we can't have here is number
10 somehow not making public the reason
why
the person who has actually been
policing the upholding of standards in
government
can't actually in public show why
they've left their job we need to see
that
and we need to see a situation where
number 10 is open about this given that
the post of ethics advisor is a prime
ministerial appointment will you have
any confidence going forward no matter
who goes into that job
who on earth do you think would want to
take that job after the situation that
we've had i mean frankly the only people
i can think of who actually condone the
rule breaking of the prime minister the
211 conservative mps who voted for him
in the vote of confidence boris johnson
is a serial rule breaker a breaker of
the law i can't think of anyone would
even want to take on that role okay
you've talked an awful lot about the
propriety or lack thereof of the of the
prime minister let's let's certainly
perhaps change the focus slightly
harriet harmon should she not recuse
herself from the privileges committee
she was discovered to have accused the
prime minister two months ago of
misleading parliament she has pre-judged
shouldn't she she do the honourable
thing as chris brown did and step away
from those committee responsibilities
well i think harry harman is a
highly respected highly experienced
parliamentarian
with a pre-held view of the prime
minister's guilt yes but which which
mp hasn't expressed views of different
kinds uh about the uh prime minister
it's not in those questions not in those
terms they haven't but look the
the committee will continue its
investigation harry harmon is a as i say
an extremely experienced very
well-respected and by the way respected
on all
sides of the house that committee needs
to now continue its investigation and
come to a conclusion about what is neil
extraordinarily serious matter which is
whether or not the prime minister
deliberately misled parliament that it's
important that work no continues
let's dwell though on rwanda and of
course we saw two days ago 450 of people
making across the channel similar
figures yesterday
in your view as things stand is there
any deterrent effect being offered by
the rwandan scheme
i think the random scheme is unethical
and i think it is unworkable
we still unfortunately see people
risking their lives in those
extraordinarily dangerous waters in the
channel
i think this is just government by
gimmick it's a government that chases
headlines and doesn't do
the hard graft that is required to
actually uh solve this problem and
prevent people from risking their lives
unethical and practical there'll be
plenty of people who agree with you why
then was it not possible for kirstar
spokesman yesterday after pmq's to
guarantee that labour if they got in at
the next election would act to repeal
this policy
i i don't know i wasn't present at the
precisely what was said but look my my
view is that
this is such an impractical policy i
think it's highly unlikely to be there
at the time of the next election but of
course let me know if you were the next
secretary would you repeal it oh yeah we
we will not be spending uh what is it
tens of millions of pounds sending
people to rwanda absolutely not i've
been very clear about that what we
actually need is a workable strategy we
need that workable deal with the french
authorities the belgian authorities too
working together to tackle organized
crime not doing what the government is
doing by the way proposing a 20 cut in
the national crime agency completely the
wrong thing to do we also need to sort
out our asylum system the government
calls it broken it is broken by them in
power for 12 years we need as well those
safe and legal routes successor to the
dublin iii regulation allowing those
safe and legal routes but also safe
returns of people who shouldn't be here
if it is if it is such a matter of
priority why on earth did keerstarman
not mention it at pmqs yesterday
well kiestarma
takes different approaches at every
single uh prime minister's questions you
you put together sex christ do you look
at the theme for the week but that isn't
an indication of what our viewers
but he also didn't talk about the
northern ireland protocol and the thing
that people identify about immigration
and indeed about the situation in north
northern ireland this for this this
phrase that apparently has become
popular over the past couple of days
wedge issues that these are issues on
which labour
not necessarily avoiding all avoiding
all debate on it but on on a week when
those have been the two dominant
political stories for the leader of the
opposition to avoid them does suggest
that he's not entirely comfortable
talking about them well on the contrary
i mean kia last week was in dublin and
was in belfast and in the course of his
career before coming in the politics has
a real history of working in northern
ireland he's passionate
about it and he's very passionate about
speaking about this issue around the
protocol so the opposite actually is the
case it's a huge priority and i've no
doubt the kiosk armor as prime minister
will be putting in that work that state
craft that would be finding a solution
at the northern ireland protocol not
taking the approach that this government
does which is entirely reckless are you
a star wars fan because of course
yesterday
decided to to to labor a metaphor about
the government some suggesting that
kirsten yesterday was a bit more i don't
know judge r binks than than luke
skywalker i mean has he taken to heart
the comments about him not punching
through not giving it enough welly not
really i think actually uh like me he
his um his children in the past my son
these days are actually into the star
wars lego so i think it is something
that
that he knows about uh so but what what
i saw yesterday at prime minister's
questions was kiestama raising those key
issues particularly around the economy
that are affecting you know all the
people who will be watching us uh this
morning and holding the prime minister
to account i was watching the prime
minister
talking about the issue of tax rises
when this is a government that's risen
the taxes have risen 15 times i was
watching the faces of the tory mps
behind him and for me the story of pmq's
was them not looking very impressed by
that don't tell me that
kirsten's performance yesterday was not
a direct response to people telling him
come on you've got to give it bigger
licks than that
no i think that he was as he always does
holding the prime minister's account on
the issues of the day clearly when the
leader of the opposition has all those
quotes from conservative backbenchers
themselves saying that the prime
minister's not up to the job of course
he's going to raise that and we saw him
doing that we didn't see many
conservative mps only up to precisely
who'd said what but why on earth should
the british public have confidence in
the prime minister 148 of his mps do not
as we did with dominic grabbed do you
want to give you the opportunity to talk
about the announcement that you're
making today this review that labour is
launching trying to get more business to
come into the uk tell us just a bit if
you can so what we are looking at now
are starter businesses what are the
things we can do to help them in the
first place what can we do to help them
grow what we're talking about are things
about access to finance
access
to skills as well looking as well at
things like public procurement can we
help businesses in that respect too and
what we are now looking at we're setting
up a review
what we're going to be asking that
review to do is to come back and to give
us those proposals that we need so that
we can encourage businesses to start up
to grow in this country we're a
pro-business pro-worker party and we
know that that partnership approach is
watching produce the growth in the
economy we so desperately need we will
talk more extensively about that the
next time i see you nick thomas simmons